[Music]
by the way i love mr baguette days here
they're my favorite same by the way that
was nice of you joe yeah you didn't even
ask us this time and and we all got
banned me so it was very nice bambi's
i wasn't even a part of it ryan just
goes and gets it so thanks ryan thank
you ryan
starbucks is a piece of [ __ ] and they're
never open never um anybody here uh love
uh speaking of love anybody here love um
weed
speaking of love i never got into weed i
mean uh i'll say what i'm saying
probably my only choice of substance
that i enjoy
now that i'm also off caffeine
your only substance you enjoy for now oh
okay for now i say i love caffeine
yeah i love cats caffeine's probably my
favorite choice don't derail my
conversation i don't like gateway drugs
i like only the hardships the hardcore
[ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] what's gateway like
wheat weed what else
pills
cough syrup coffee with cough syrup
sound bath though that shit's [ __ ]
crazy consider the conversation d-ring
banana drill is kind of fire
and you gotta like fight it a little bit
and trying to stay up after you take a
like those two little nighttime pills oh
yes uh speaking of weed so um
snoop dogg has a full-time blunt roller
do you guys know that yeah i've heard of
it there's like a guy on payroll yeah
rogan has one too yeah it's a it's a
dream i've always wanted a full-time
right so he travels with you to roll
blunts for you he's literally full-time
and he says snoop dogg says like this
guy has impeccable timing like that's
his super skill not only is he a really
really good blunt roller but he just
knows the right time to like
the random one he's like he's in a
meeting he's gonna need one right now in
30 minutes gives his full-time blunt
roller anywhere from like 40 to 50
dollars as a salary annually wow and uh
recently uh uh you know one of those
like uh twitter fact
kind of
accounts or whatever was like snoop
dogg's got a a full-time blood roll he
pays him this much and then snoop dogg
responded to it and he was like
inflation had to give him a raise so
now the news is he gets even more than
fifty thousand dollars a year for him to
be his full-time blunt roller wow isn't
that the best [ __ ] life ever dude do
you have write-offs though what are the
write-offs snoop rolls pretty [ __ ]
deep with his entourage so when i was at
maker snoop would shoot a show there and
he had like [ __ ] 30 dudes there he
had a barbecue crew who always was there
and they had this like big blue tent and
they were always outside i knew what
snoop was there because you could
actually smell the weed from the parking
lot that sounds like a bit it's not it's
not so he had barbecue and wheat so he
had like a barbecue staff that would
roll with them and set up a barbecue
that's real power actually yeah that's
really cool a production company that
works with uh snoop and mike tyson same
thing they always roll with the
entourage always have catering
apparently like they show up very late
but they're really nice
yes hours and hours late for sure you
just gotta put like all of you need to
bring his 40s staff member he's like a
traveling caravan like he's like genghis
khan with his [ __ ] warriors and [ __ ]
you know like a street fair was outside
like that is honestly how it was that's
pretty cool that's how life needs to
always be though right like just rolling
with the entourage so deep that like
you're even surprised by your entourage
i feel like they're because we've we've
worked with quest crew we've worked with
snoop uh like three times and the the
crew that he rolls with it is super deep
but you can't even tell who the blunt
roller is
i feel like they're all the blunt
rollers
is there like a blunt roller a shoe
maker a like a shoe shiner it just looks
like they're all doing that
everyone's rolling blind cobbler
i went to i went to a party in vegas
[Laughter]
he has a [ __ ] piano he's black what
does he have a black line i mean
african-american smith he has a warlock
[ __ ] manga
he has a [ __ ] mage in the back
[ __ ] dude but yeah they are they are
all super nice
and they're very like they're very like
inviting they always want everyone
smoking and come smoke we have so much
weed super fun
the less we get in trouble wow
that's a huge entrepreneur i went to a
vegas party one time uh that eventually
led me to apparently some sort of i
don't know if he was like a pimp
uh but he had a big mansion it was in
vegas i remember once we got there to
this party uh there was like he had like
pet wolves and [ __ ] i remember right
when we walked in there was like seven
cars like nice ass cars with a huge rv
outside his garage there was a shark
tank with a shark in it in the living
room that poor shark dude
that poor happy shark was a full-size
shark
and then there was also his like in the
in like the second living room
in the second living room there's a
circle bed that's just in the middle of
the living room obviously for [ __ ]
because there's a giant mirror on the
ceiling right
now that could also be for break dancing
it could be for right now and i'll
remember this place because killer whale
he didn't have a killer orchestra
he's just gonna pull the killer
designated blunt roller
the water designated a blunt roller
there and literally for like we're
probably there for like four hours this
is the biggest flex
this this dude is literally just [ __ ]
rolling blunts and every single time he
finished it he would just hand it to the
next person that was next to him
although it's for everyone there was
literally just blind
but for blunts yeah but but you wouldn't
wait in line for it he would literally
just be there the whole night and if you
happen to pass him he was just handing
you the next auntie making egg rolls for
the party yes oh it was more like that
or would he be like i already gave you
one i saw you pass it down to the shark
not with weed culture you're just
constant it's just constant there's like
a blunt rolling committee and the best
of the best gets like
like bought by different
groups and like a blunt rolling
championship i think so i think because
snoop's like this is my roller and then
that pimp guy has his own roller or
maybe it's the same guy and then they
get higher that's just word of mouth you
know me and like that whole industry as
if it's a national industry yeah it's
like you go to a party one guy [ __ ]
is a blunt roller rolls the sweetest
blunts are you proud of your life
rolling though are you really good no
not at all because i don't i'm to me
blunts are so massive
i take to me it's so wasteful i take one
hit and i'm like done yeah i can't i
can't finish who smokes the whole whole
blood even in halo because i'm such a
[ __ ] it's like it makes you makes me
cough immediately yeah i have to gummy
it or i'm [ __ ] but i don't even like
that i i've never finished a blow on my
own so this this guy was really a pimp
that's what he did
the biggest guy part of the story
yeah
when were
they're ladies of the night ladies of
the night there let's focus on the blood
rolling guys no no no no no no no
that was the gateway part of the story i
don't do gateway drugs you know what man
hey did you rail chicks in the red light
district
i'm just saying
no
dudes are a difference no nobody asks me
how come no one asks we know your
stories joe what was it like what was it
like did you rail chicks in the red
light district which red light red light
exactly
did you do did you perform kind of like
in the red light district
yeah i keep hearing that as a recurring
joke is that is that no that's not a
joke that's real life real that's just a
[Laughter]
ever wants to bring out my story
so how did how'd it go
oh it's another story for another time
you know for another video next video
it was a long time ago it was uh
it was actually a legal brothel in
america my friend was taking me out
there for my birthday but i was an
excuse because he was very addicted to
having sex with ladies of the night and
he kept selling it to me and i was like
dude that sounds so good any occasion i
just can't justify paying a couple
hundred dollars for this you know but at
the same time um i don't think i had sex
in like two months or something it was a
long time and i was like man but you
know
that does sound kind of nice you know if
you're gonna pay for it and it's my
birthday then we can go and then we did
this thing and by that time i was so
[ __ ] horny i just [ __ ]
[Laughter]
he goes
you wanted your team
yeah that's funny she like oh what are
you doing
what are you doing down there she's just
like hey patty look at this guy
girls come in here this is crazy it's
happening again i told you i could do it
it's opposite day at the brothel i guess
and then i got to and then i got to
finish also the nachos of the sex tavera
joe over here it's like dude it was like
two months it's been a long time i gotta
go [ __ ] a hooker maybe it was three
or do you think afterwards she was like
oh no i think he had something wrong or
something
i had a special voice bless his heart
like i thought i felt so bad i was like
okay well that's fine jill i got
cunnilingus again i think i think he's
on the spectrum yeah it's okay love on
the spectrum love on the special dude
that's a good show that's the greatest
show of all time this is the greatest
show of all time i have not gotten
around to watching it it's like you're
great it's better than the little
japanese kids have to do adult tests
oh yeah
that sounds like when the kid drops his
fish on the floor and he's like he keeps
[ __ ] it up
my favorite one is the add boy the one
that had to make orange juice it's one
of the first episodes but he used he had
to make orange juice and the [ __ ] he
it took him two hours and he he kept a
hard task deadpool got a net and you
started chasing the puppy around for
like an hour
i wonder why that's your favorite
yeah only on this show can we go from
cunnilingus on a hooker right into
japanese kids making
you brought it up to you
don't point and laugh at the same time
you're enabling me you gateway
what do you guys think about a show
you put a bunch of monkeys in business
suits and and you put them in an office
and you just kind of call it the monkey
office
and then you just sort of see what
happens what do you think what happened
well we what we do is we have everything
tied to actual other parts of a business
like a ship like shipping downstairs a
lot of stuff so whatever the monkeys do
we'll see how they can run a business
i think it'd be the greatest [ __ ]
show of all time do you pitch it to
animal planet or
i don't know i don't know who wants the
show would you pitch it to peta
there's people in a warehouse waiting to
ship products
if they get the call it's gonna be
called amazon primate
i love all right dude end the video
that's perfect amazon
anthony is soaked right now you guys
can't see he's so genius dude i'm trying
to think of one right now
what
monkey business monkey business it was
right there
joe goes what
[Music]